Back in 1603, Queen Elizabeth I passed away.
She had ruled England for 45 years, was well-loved,
and provided a sense of stability and security
during her reign.
Described as “neither a good protestant
nor yet resolute papist,” she was able to
provide a relatively happy medium between
the two warring sects.
Having had no children of her own, though,
the throne was open to King James VI of Scotland,
who became King James I of England upon her
death.
England had been at war with Scotland on and
off over the years.
James’ own mother, Mary, had been beheaded
by Elizabeth.
Still, many people saw the rise of a new king
to be the opportunity for religious reform
that they had been waiting for.
On his journey south to his English coronation,
King James was stopped by a delegation of
Puritans who presented him with a list of
grievances and proposed reforms.
It was signed by over 1000 clergymen—10%
of England’s clergy at the time—and was
subsequently called the Millenary Petition.
They addressed things such as banning the
use of wedding rings and wearing a cross,
but didn’t mention anything about a new
bible translation.
The new King James called for a meeting at
Hampton Court Palace to address the concerns
in the Millenary Petition, which took place
in early 1604.
The Puritans weren’t allowed to attend the
first day of the conference, and James largely
disregarded most of their requests.
In fact, James was happy with the set-up of
the English Church, having been extremely
frustrated with the Scottish Presbyterian
model.
Eventually, Dr. John Reynolds, the lead Puritan
voice at the conference, brought up the idea
of a bible translation because “those which
were allowed in the reign of King Henry VIII
and King Edward VI were corrupt and not answerable
to the truth of the original.”
James, who hated the popular Geneva bible
for its anti-royalty message, agreed that
a new translation would be for the best.
And despite the other outcomes of the conference,
the Puritans were happy because they believed
they would have a say in the new translation,
perhaps enabling them to bring about some
of the reforms they wished for anyway.
The translation of the bible didn’t begin
until 1607.
Fifty-four bible experts (only forty-eight
were recorded, as some died before the translation
was finished) gathered at Oxford, Westminster,
and Cambridge to discuss the translation.
They came from all levels of religion and
had different ideas about the reform that
they wanted to see.
They had to follow 15 rules for translation,
including making no notes in the margins of
the Bible and keeping the language accessible
to the common people (many of whom were wholly
illiterate at the time).
The translators were broken into subcommittees.
Each translator independently translated the
same section of the bible, which he then brought
back to the subcommittee.
All of the translations were compared, and
one was selected to be sent to the general
revising committee.
The revising committee listened to the translation
rather than read it; because much of their
audience was illiterate, they wanted the bible
to sound right more than look right.
If the translation didn’t sound good, the
general committee would debate and revise
the passage until it did.
Afterwards, they would send their approved
passages to a few Bishops, who would then
send the passage on to the Archbishop of Canterbury,
who would send it to King James who had the
final say in the approval of the new translation.
The new translation was finally completed
in1610, but didn’t become available to the
public until the following year.
It was printed by Robert Barker, King James’
personally appointed printer.
Unfortunately, the new translation had been
so anticipated that Barker rushed to the printer
and many mistakes were made.
Barker had paid £3,500 for the right to publish
the bible, and spent even more trying to fix
mistakes and fend off pirating publishers.
By 1635, he ended up in debtor’s prison
where he would later die.
Aside from printing two different versions
of the bible at the same time and allowing
their pages to get bound up together rather
than separately, major typos were discovered
in the 1631 printing, which later became known
as “The Wicked Bible.”
Among other discrepancies, “God’s greatness”
was misprinted as “God’s great asse”
and the word “not” was left out of the
commandment “Thou shalt not commit adultery.”
Because of this, it isn’t exactly a mystery
as to why the King James Version wasn’t
popular from the start.
Over time, the King James Bible underwent
a number of revisions from the original translation.
Typos were corrected, new chapter summaries
were included, and marginal references were
added and verified for accuracy.
The revisions opened the door to increasing
the King James Version’s popularity.